[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANAND IYER: I am really
excited to be here
to talk about a topic
that I personally
am quite passionate about,
which is taking data
as it's being produced
and deriving insights
from that data in real time
to drive business decisions
and actions.
So over the-- let me set the
agenda of what we will cover
over the next 45 to 50 minutes.
This is a 100 level introductory
talk on stream processing,
on real-time stream
processing, with a focus
on business use cases enabled
by real-time stream processing.
So what we'll do is we'll
cover common stream processing
architectural patterns.
So I'll highlight the
architectural pattern.
And for each
architectural pattern,
I will pair that with a
few real world use cases
that leverage that pattern.
So this is a very
pragmatic talk.
We'll cover pragmatic
patterns and use cases.
So let me also talk about
what we will not cover.
What we'll not cover is we
won't be going under the hood
and look at how the
various stream processing
technologies actually work.
So we won't look
at how they work.
We'll look at how to use
them for your use cases.
We'll also not be looking
at snippets of code.
We won't go to the code level.
We'll stay at the
architectural pattern level.
The second half of
this talk is actually
what I suspect will be
more compelling to you.
We are fortunate to have Syarif
Hidayatullah from GO-JEK come
here, and join us, and talk
to us about various stream
processing use cases, business
use cases, implemented
at GO-JEK.
And a lot of these use
cases have actually
been implemented by Syarif,
who is a data engineer.
So we are very fortunate
to have him here
to talk about these use cases.
GO-JEK is a fascinating company.
It is a fast-growing
company based in Indonesia,
and they have a
presence in other parts
of Southeast Asia as well.
They have a bunch of
offerings, and I'll
let Syarif talk about
GO-JEK in more detail.
But let me just
give you a preview.
Most of the noteworthy
offerings are in ride hailing
and logistics or delivery.
So really excited to have
Syarif to talk about how they've
implemented business use cases
that leverage real-time stream
processing.
And towards the end, we'll
leave a few minutes for Q&A.
So before we dive into the
architectural patterns,
let's take a step back and
look at the big building
blocks for most end-to-end
real-time stream processing
applications.
So at the very left,
we have the sources
of data, the applications
that are generating
the continuous streams of data
that we will be processing.
The first thing you want to do
is take those streams of data
and write them to a
reliable, scalable, high
throughput streaming
data channel.
Think of this as the big pipes
through which your streaming
data moves.
And the two most common
options are Apache Kafka,
which is a popular open
source option, which
is available on Google Cloud.
And then the other
option is Pub/Sub,
which is Google's fully managed
and serverless offering.
Well, after you've
ingested the data,
often, that data is going to
be in raw format, not a format
that is amenable for analysis.
So you want to
take that raw data
and transform that
data into a format that
is much better for analysis.
And you do that in real-time
stream processing engines.
And on Google Cloud, the
two most common options,
the recommended options, are
either Dataproc or Dataflow.
So Dataproc is Google's
managed offering
for the popular open
source distributed
processing engine Apache Spark.
Dataflow is Google's cloud
native solution for both stream
and batch processing,
and Dataflow
is a fully managed and
serverless offering.
Well, so after you've
transformed the data,
now it's ready to be analyzed.
You can do the analysis in
Dataflow or Dataproc itself.
Both offer fairly flexible
programmatic SDKs.
So you can do arbitrary
analysis and processing
within Dataflow or Dataproc.
But another common pattern is
you take the transform data,
and you write it into BigQuery.
BigQuery is infinitely scalable,
fully-managed, SQL-based data
warehouse in the cloud.
So once the data is
written to BigQuery,
you can issue SQL queries to
BigQuery and analyze the data.
So great.
At this point, we have
analyzed the data,
and you have likely derived the
insight that is of interest.
But the whole point of
real-time stream processing
is to make that insight, or
the results of our analysis,
actionable in real time.
That invariably means there
has to be some end user facing
application where the insight
or the results of the analysis
are served.
And to do that, we write
the analysis, the systems,
to data stores that
can serve the data.
Common options here
are NoSQL stores,
such as Bigtable and Datastore.
Cloud Spanner is a
transactional database
that is increasingly becoming
popular for stream processing
use cases.
And, of course, you can
write the data to BigQuery,
because when a SQL query
is issued to BigQuery, say
through the JDBC client, it
immediately serves the result.
So you need some system to serve
the results to the end user
applications, and that
happens to BigQuery, Bigtable,
Datastore, or Spanner.
There are other options as well.
You can use Cloud SQL,
and so on, and so forth.
But in stream processing,
these four options listed here
tend to be the common options.
Now, I do want to highlight
that on Google Cloud,
these tools are
seamlessly integrated
so that you can focus on
your application logic.
And the APIs are neatly
integrated for you
to transfer data from
one system to the other,
to read data and write data
from one system to the other.
And the other thing
I want to highlight
is most of these tools are
managed, and some of them
are serverless.
And what I mean by managed
and serverless is a managed
offering is one
where you as a user
do not have to worry about
spinning up clusters, managing
clusters, managing VMs,
and scaling up and down.
And serverless
offerings are where
you can just forget that there's
a cluster in the background.
You just submit your workload.
We take care of spinning
up VMs on your behalf,
scaling them up and
down, and so forth.
So it's really compelling,
because these are all
seamlessly integrated, and
many of them are managed
and serverless.
So with that, let's dive
into some specific patterns.
But first, let me
set some context.
For simplicity, when I
talk about a pattern,
I will have an
architectural diagram that
just focuses on the pattern.
And just to keep
things consistent,
we'll focus on using Pub/Sub
as our default streaming data
channel, and we'll use
Dataflow as our default stream
processing tool of choice.
I do want to highlight that
in real world use cases,
you will actually be combining
a bunch of these patterns.
But over here, just
for simplicity,
so when you look at an
architectural diagram,
it's easy to read,
I'll just highlight
one pattern at a time.
I just want to repeat,
real world use cases
will clearly be a
combination of these.
And when you look
at Syarif's talk,
that actually becomes
very apparent.
And before we move on,
just one piece of advice.
Always archive the raw data.
With stream processing,
mistakes will happen.
And often, mistakes happen
because of errors in user code.
And if you've not
archived the data,
it can become
difficult to recover.
But if you've archived
the data, then you
can always backfill recover
by running a batch job
and so forth.
So just a rule of thumb, always
be safe, archive the raw data.
And of course, you don't need
to keep the archived data
for years on end.
Keep it for a few
months, and then
when you know that
things have worked fine,
you can discard
the archive data.
And often, archiving the
data has very little cost.
All right.
So with that, let's dive
into the first pattern.
The very first pattern I want
to talk about is very simple.
It just entails reading the data
streams, events that come in,
and writing them
directly into BigQuery.
BigQuery has an API called
the BigQuery Streaming API.
It's a high throughput
streaming API.
And as soon as you write
an event into BigQuery
through this API, any SQL
query issued to BigQuery
thereafter will
have results that
incorporate these new events.
So in many cases, to
do real-time processing
of data, all you have to do is
stream the data into BigQuery
as it comes in.
Of course, that
won't always work.
This works when your data
comes in a JSON format.
And often, you want the
fields of the records
to match the columns
of your table.
There are non-trivial use
cases where that is the case.
You have JSON data coming in.
It maps to the
fields of your table.
You just write it in,
and you're good to go.
And often, real-time
stream processing
is as simple as that.
And I did mention,
this is pragmatic talk.
I'm not always going to get
into a sophisticated stream
processing.
And in many cases,
this is all you need,
and you're good to go.
But of course, that's not
going to be true all the time.
And in most cases,
you will need to do
some processing of
the data, because it
comes in a raw format.
And you want to do some
transformations to convert it
from whatever raw format
it came in to some slightly
structured format that
is amenable for analysis.
In many cases, you will
get malformed data,
and you want to filter
out the malformed data.
As you're doing the
transformation and cleaning,
you might convert
data from strings
to more structured
fields, like date time
fields and [INAUDIBLE] fields
and [? flows ?] and so forth.
So you do that in
Cloud Dataflow.
In Cloud Dataflow, you
can take the incoming data
and process each
event one by one.
So over here, we're talking
about something fairly simple,
where you're not looking
at multiple events
and aggregation.
You're actually looking at
each event in isolation.
And of course, in many
cases, the events coming in
are not going to have
all the information
you need to do your analysis.
So what you need to
do, in many cases,
is join the incoming data
with relevant metadata that
will be in other data stores.
And common data stores
that hold metadata might
be in some BigQuery table.
It could be in Bigtable,
or Spanner, or even
other relational
databases like Cloud SQL.
So you join the incoming
data with relevant metadata
from other data stores, so
you have enriched your data.
And now, you have your
transformed, clean, filtered,
enriched data, you
write it into BigQuery,
and you're ready for analysis.
Now I do want to highlight
that systems like Dataflow,
the SDKs provide very
easy to use operators.
So you merely invoke
the operator [INAUDIBLE]
transformations, or
filtering, or joins.
And often, you actually have
to provide just a small snippet
of code that
contains your custom
logic that determines what you
want to do with the events.
So the SDKs make all
of this very easy.
And of course, these systems
are integrated, so moving data
from one place to the other
is also incredibly easy,
thanks to the pre-built APIs.
Now let's talk about
business use cases.
When it comes to writing data
to BigQuery in real time,
this is applicable across
industries and business use
cases.
This is applicable
in any situation
where you're using
metrics and dashboards
to run your business,
which increasingly
is most businesses.
In many cases, you just
stream the data in,
and you now are
having dashboards.
Or when you issue a
BI query, the results
reflect what happened now.
They're not reflecting
what happened yesterday.
And I want to contrast this
with what happens traditionally,
where you might have a
daily job, an ETL job--
ETL is the term commonly used.
You have an ETL job that's
taking your raw data
and doing a whole bunch of
transformations in a batch
format, and then loading it
into your analytic warehouse.
Now, don't get me wrong.
There will still be use
cases where you need
to do that batch processing.
Because whatever
analysis you're doing in
that job may not be amenable
for a streaming pattern.
But if you look
at your ETL jobs,
you'll find that a significant
chunk of those jobs
can be converted
to streaming jobs.
And if you convert them
to a streaming job,
dashboards that are
powered by that data
reflect the state of the world
as of now, not as of yesterday,
or as of last week.
Very cool.
So now, let's look at a slightly
more sophisticated pattern,
where you're actually looking
at a whole bunch of events
together.
In many scenarios,
what you're interested,
particularly when you're talking
about real-time analysis, what
you're interested in is what
happened in a very recent,
or the most recent
window of time.
What you're interested
in knowing is,
what happened in the
most recent 30 seconds,
or the most recent
say, five minutes,
or maybe even couple of hours.
But the key thing is you
want to know what happened
in a recent window of time.
And as time proceeds, you want
to constantly look and analyze
what happened within
the most recent window.
And to do that, you use
fixed or sliding windows.
There's a subtle
difference between the two.
Fixed windows don't overlap.
So one window ends, and
the next window begins.
And then with sliding
windows, you actually
have a large window that
moves a little bit every time.
So there is overlap
across subsequent windows.
And depending on your use case,
you can use one or the other.
Essentially, you pick the
type of window you want.
You invoke the window
within your code,
and you provide
another snippet of code
that determines how you want
to process the events that
fit into a particular window.
And then the framework
essentially handles the rest.
The framework will handle
the creation of these windows
and the collection of the
events that fit into a window,
and essentially it will
keep track of time.
And as soon as a
window completes,
as soon as it completes, it'll
call your snippet of code,
analyze the events that
fell into that window.
So the framework simplifies
this windowing process
significantly.
So now let's look at use cases
that are enabled by this.
And there are a whole
bunch of use cases.
Let me start with
retail and e-commerce,
because they often tend
to be use cases that
are easy to understand
and empathize with.
So with e-commerce,
let's say you want
to keep track of popular items.
You want to know items
that are becoming popular
as soon as that trend
starts to surface.
And you may not really
care about the popularity
of that item last
week or yesterday,
because you want to
catch trends early.
So what you do is you
keep track of the searches
that people are issuing
in the e-commerce website,
and you're analyzing
the searches
that came in within, say,
the past couple of hours.
And then, you know the
products that are popular now.
And then you can match that
with your inventory to know
if, let's just say, the
inventory cannot keep up with
the demand.
Or if demand is higher
than the inventory,
then you can do dynamic pricing.
Similar use cases where you
might have some product quality
issues, a new batch
of products came in,
and they have some defects.
And now you're
seeing a high number
of complaints or returns.
And we want to capture
that very quickly.
And when you're
capturing this, you're
not really interested in the
number of returns or complaints
that came in last week.
You want to know what happened
in the past, say, few hours.
And again, fixed and
sliding windows enabled.
There are similar use cases
in IT operations, where you're
tracking metrics, and you can
see how that metric is moving
over a recent window of time.
And you can also contrast that
with historical information.
It's also particularly
common in finance,
where for stock
trading strategies,
a lot of their
strategies actually
look at multiple windows
of time simultaneously,
because they want to know
how the stock is moving.
So a bunch of use
cases that leverage
fixed and sliding windows.
One more use case
before we move on.
There are certain use
cases where you're not
necessarily interested
in what happened
in the most recent window.
What you want to
do is you actually
want to do some
smoothing and denoising.
And this is particularly
true in IoT,
where you have a lot
of cheap sensors,
and these sensors are
sending information.
But the information coming
in is often very noisy.
There's a whole bunch of noise.
And you don't want to be
making big decisions based
on the value of
one censor reading.
So an easy way to deal
with that is you define
a reasonable window of time.
And you just average
out, say, the sensor
values within that window.
So that essentially serves as a
simple denoising and smoothing
technique, which is
common in IoT use cases,
and it's also applied in
similar other use cases.
Very cool.
So moving on, now let's talk
about a fairly distinct,
but very popular
type of windowing
called session windowing.
And this is useful
for consumer internet
and mobile applications.
Essentially, what
session windows
are used for is collecting
your click logs.
All the activity that users
perform on the web application,
or the mobile application,
all that information
is streaming in.
And what you want to do is
isolate each user session
so you can analyze what
happened within that session.
So this is different from
fixed and sliding windows,
because the windows
are not fixed.
And also, you have a
separate window per user.
So all you have to do
is, in the framework,
you just have to
mention, what is
the field in your
incoming events
that corresponds to the user ID?
And then the framework will
automatically split the events
based on that user ID.
And then you have to pass
another parameter, which
is the duration
of inactivity that
signifies the end of a session.
Because there are many ways
you know a session has ended.
The most common way tends
to be, OK, the person
is no longer active
on my application,
so lets consider the
session to be done.
So you specify these
two parameters.
What is the key that
specifies the user ID?
And what is the
duration of inactivity
that signifies the
end of a session.
And the framework
handles the rest.
The framework will
take these events,
split these events
by ID, determine
when a window has ended, and as
soon as that window has ended,
it will invoke your
snippet of code.
And no surprises here.
This is used by consumer
internet mobile applications
to understand how
users are navigating
through that application.
Because what you
are able to do is
get the events that
fell within a session,
so you can actually understand
the fact that the user came in,
may have issued a search
query, then clicked
on a certain button,
stayed on this certain page
for a certain duration of
time, and so on and so forth.
So you analyze each session,
write the results to BigQuery,
and now you actually have
an aggregated view of how
users navigated through
your application.
And this is a very common
use case, particularly when
you are deploying new
versions of your application
or you're doing A/B testing.
You want to identify
mistakes soon.
You want to identify something
you might have shipped
that is leading to a significant
drop in a certain usage
pattern that is critical.
So as soon as you
run your A/B test,
you have your streaming job
analyzing user sessions,
identify issues quickly,
and maybe roll back.
It's a very common use, and
a fairly distinct use case
that was worth calling out.
So that was windowing.
So moving along, now,
let's talk about a topic
that is likely to be popular,
GCP and Google Cloud Next.
Machine learning is clearly
a theme of the conference.
And in many scenarios, you
want to apply machine learning
within a streaming context.
Actually, a quick show of hands.
I am curious to know how
many folks in the audience
are interested in
applying machine
learning on streaming data?
All right.
That's as I suspected.
There's a lot of interest.
Now, in this
particular scenario,
I'm talking about users
training their own custom
models for their use case.
And that training,
that heavy lifting,
happens in a batch
format, and it happens not
within the streaming engine.
It'll happen in something like,
Cloud Machine Learning CMLE,
which is Cloud Machine
Learning Engine, that
lets you train your own models.
In this particular diagram,
I'm using TensorFlow,
because that was the
most recognizable logo
that I could use to
signify machine learning.
But, of course, you can train
other modules, [INAUDIBLE]..
There are a bunch
of other frameworks
that let you do
machine learning.
Of course, the heavy
lifting is happening
where you're training a
machine learning model.
But once it's trained, you can
leverage that trained model
within your
streaming application
and to do inference or
scoring on the events
as they stream in.
Now, of course, before
you can do the scoring--
and I want to
reiterate the fact here
that a real-world
use case will employ
a bunch of other patterns
that we mentioned.
Often, before you can pass the
data to the machine learning
model, you'll be doing a whole
bunch of transformations.
Joining and enriching the
data from external metastores
is very common, because
you want to fetch features.
You do the transformation,
create the feature vector,
pass it to the
model for scoring.
Now some of you may be thinking
that this doesn't sound
very remarkable because
it's rather simple to take
a machine learning
model and invoke it
within the context of a
streaming application.
And that is true.
As an architectural
pattern, it's
not tremendously remarkable.
But I wanted to reaffirm the
fact that this is happening.
This is a very common pattern.
And it's actually a very
easy to implement pattern.
And often, withing your
new streaming application,
you can constantly be checking
to see if a new model has been
produced, and when a
new model is produced,
you take the new model.
Or often, customers even
run some A/B testing,
where they're using
a bunch of models
to score different events
and see what's happening.
I just wanted to reaffirm that
this is a very easy pattern
to implement with GCP
tools, particularly
when you're using something like
Cloud Machine Learning Engine.
And customers are doing it--
increasingly common
pattern, and a lot more
customers are doing it.
So let's look at
a few use cases.
E-commerce and finance,
real-time fraud detection.
That's sort of the poster child
for real-time stream processing
and machine learning.
So I actually won't
beat that horse anymore.
I'll move on.
There are other use cases.
For example,
digital advertising,
where you have all the click
and impression information
streaming in all the time.
And you can use
that in real time
to determine what
ads have the highest
proclivity of being clicked.
So as the data streams in, you
apply a machine learning model,
and you can determine
what is the right ad
to show for subsequent
users that come in.
Now, these are all,
again, fairly, I
guess, relatively
known use cases,
because digital advertising
has been around for a while.
And particularly,
it's gratifying
to talk about use
cases in health care,
where literally lives
are being saved.
A very commonly
referenced use case
is one of doing
sepsis identification.
Sepsis is a condition
that happens after fairly
invasive operations.
It's a type of infection.
And historically,
nurses would have
to keep checking
in on the patient
periodically to see how
they're doing, to see
if they're at risk for sepsis.
But now, because patients are
connected to various devices
and you're monitoring their
vital statistics, as that data
streams in, you
can apply a machine
learning model
that can determine
who's at risk for sepsis.
And if a patient is
identified, a pager alert
can go out to a nurse.
So the nurses don't have to
proactively keep checking,
and you can offer
more proactive care
to the post-operative patients.
It was a particularly gratifying
use case to talk about.
Now, in the previous example,
the user had to build a machine
learning model.
But that's not always true.
Again, at Next, you
might have visited
a bunch of talks, where we
spoke about the machine learning
APIs that do the machine
learning for you.
You give us the data, the
images, or the speech,
and so forth, and we
apply the machine learning
and return the results.
And invoking these APIs
from a streaming application
is, again, an increasingly
common pattern.
And again, it may
seem unremarkable,
because, again, the heavy
lifting is happening
in the machine learning APIs.
That is actually true.
This is, come to think of
it, a fairly easy pattern
to implement, but it's an
increasingly common pattern.
And just one piece of advice.
When you're calling these
APIs, for proper performance,
you want to limit
the amount of data
that's going over the network.
So commonly, what
people will do is
they'll use a fixed window,
or even a sliding window,
but often, a fixed
window, just to get
a group of few [INAUDIBLE],,
and then make batch
calls to the API.
So rather, make calls to the
APIs with a batch of data,
rather than calling the
API each individual time.
But again, this is a
very simple pattern,
but it enables some fairly
compelling use cases.
And let me walk through these.
There's one use case-- and
these are actually use cases
that customers have implemented.
There's one use
case where, if you
have multiplayer
online sessions,
this is where a bunch of folks
are wearing their headsets
and microphones and they're
playing, say, a first person
shooter, or "World of
Warcraft," or what have you,
they're constantly
talking to each other,
and they're playing
against each other.
Sometimes, these sessions
actually turn verbally abusive.
This is a common problem.
And now, with the
speech to text APIs,
as that speech information
comes in, you invoke the API.
You convert that speech to text.
And when you convert
that text, you
apply NLP techniques to identify
when it's becoming abusive.
And then you can take corrective
action in that session.
Another use case is finance
where, for trading strategies,
you want to consume
the world's newest
information about various
organizations of the world.
Thomson Reuters, for
example, serves a whole bunch
of financial news.
You want to consume that
news information, invoke
NLP APIs to identify the
entities mentioned in the news
articles, and also the
sentiment of the news article,
and that is a rich source
of information to determine
trading strategies.
Another example,
which is, I guess,
a de jure example, in today's
world, is for home security,
where you have your security
camera feeds coming in,
and you can invoke Vision
APIs to identify entities
in the image frames,
and you can use
that to dynamically
determine when there might
be a physical threat outside
that security cameras,
outside your home, and so forth.
So very cool.
Simple pattern, but
very useful pattern.
Now, the last pattern
I want to talk about
is a slightly more sophisticated
pattern than the other ones
we've discussed so far.
It's called stateful
streaming, and this
is a pattern where,
as the events flow by,
you're maintaining some state
information about the entities
and your events, and you're
using that state information
to make some business decision.
And, again, the key thing
here is the framework
really simplifies this.
It gives you APIs where, based
on a key such as a user ID,
you can add state information,
and that information
is kept in memory.
You can add state information.
You can read the state
information and take action,
or you can update that
state information.
So you as a user often just
have to write snippets of code
to do the look up and
update operations.
And then the framework
handles the rest.
The framework will make
sure that the state
information-- and it can
be arbitrary information.
It's up to the application
to decide what is maintained.
The framework will make
sure that this information
is maintained in
memory and is available
in a performant fashion.
And these are often
distributed applications.
So it'll make sure that
full tolerance is covered.
If a VM goes down, for
example, the state information
isn't lost.
The framework will
take care of that.
So you, as a user, just have
to focus on your look up update
operations often.
So let me start with one
use case where this is used.
The use case is e-commerce,
where you have click events,
and events that tell you
about the activity of the user
on the e-commerce website.
As these events come
by, you can keep
information-- the
user, for example,
searched for these products.
The user added a certain
product to their cart,
removed a certain
product from their cart,
and so on, and so forth.
And based on that information,
as the next event comes in,
you can dynamically
determine how to personalize
the experience of the user.
So can you
dynamically determine,
for example, that, hey, the user
removed an item from the cart,
but is still searching
for similar items.
Let me give them an offer,
or let me dynamically adjust
the recommendations that are
made for similar products,
and so forth.
So that's what stateful stream
processing enables, and there
are other use cases as well.
For example, we have a
customer in mobile gaming.
They're dynamically customizing
the difficulty level
of the mobile application
when they identify
that a user is getting stuck.
So a whole bunch of
streaming patterns, and we
did a whirlwind tour
of common patterns.
And next, please join
me in welcoming Syarif
to stage and talk GO-JEK,
and how they're using
real-time stream processing.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
SYARIF HIDAYATULLAH: So
good afternoon, everyone.
I'm Syarif from GO-JEK.
I'm the engineer
from GO-JEK in BI,
and today, I want
to share with you
about the real-world
examples of GO-JEK
using Dataflow as
our data streaming
and [? page ?] pipeline.
So GO-JEK is an
information [INAUDIBLE] app
that has specialized
in transport
for delivery and payments.
And GO-JEK started in 2010
with only call center,
with no application
located object services.
GO-JEK is like ride
hailing service motorcycle
in Indonesia.
And in 2015, GO-JEK launched an
app with only three services.
We have GO-MART, we have
GO-FOOD, and GO-RIDE itself.
And in 2016, GO-JEK
have expansion
in 50 big cities in Indonesia,
and have created new services
since.
And this is our obligation,
our service, by now.
We have currently 18 products
serving very different needs.
And this is GO-JEK's
footprint nationwide.
Currently, we have
one million driver,
which completed three
million trips per day.
And our application
already [INAUDIBLE]
more than 76 million
downloads, and we
have more than 200,000 merchants
in 50 big cities in Indonesia.
And we move to our
GO-JEK data growth.
So in BI, these are
our current stats.
In second quarter of 2018,
from the previous month
until this month, our
data growing more than 30%
per month.
And from that data, we're
going to create more than 700
multi-resolution data sets.
And from that, we can create
more than 20,000 data points.
From our data analysis, they
create the Metabase and Tableau
sheets.
And from there, they create up
more than 13,000 Metabase cards
and Tableau sheets.
And our user, with our
analysts, created--
the user is more than
2,000 at the moment.
And this number is
increasing day by day.
It means we need
more big platform
and more scale for data.
So what is the challenge from
the previous architecture
we have?
Previously, we use
[INAUDIBLE] SQL, [INAUDIBLE],,
and also the Python script.
And the previous
architecture, we
have a report at day plus
one, so we couldn't identify
the problems at the moment.
And we also had a concern about
that the processing power,
because data comes in
batch, and it's already big,
so we need the process over
two billion data in one shot,
because it's big.
So we need a bigger machine with
bigger RAM, with bigger CPU.
And it takes a long time
to process the data.
And the business needs more
real-time data insights.
So previously, we
use [INAUDIBLE] SQL.
As you may know,
that [INAUDIBLE] SQL
needs maintenance
daily, weekly, monthly.
At least you have to
archive your data.
You have to
[INAUDIBLE] your data,
and you have to index your
data to remain your query fast.
And you also need to
maintain the [INAUDIBLE] SQL
server itself.
And we also use [INAUDIBLE]
to do our ETL batch,
which [INAUDIBLE].
Then, what's next?
We move to our GCP platform.
And what we want is we want
high performance scalability
with minimal operational
maintenance using Dataflow,
with more granular
data with high velocity
and less latency using
stream processing.
And we want the ability
to solve these problems
with real-time data insights.
So at the moment, we use
Stackdriver to monitor or log
jobs and the machine.
And we use TCS our data lake.
We use BigQuery as our
analytical purpose database.
We use Pub/Sub to deliver
our stream message.
And we use Dataflow for our
streaming data pipeline.
So we move to the use case.
Before we move to
the use case, I
want to show you about
the GO-JEK goals.
So what is GO-JEK goals?
The GO-JEK goals is on
the North Star metric.
So what is North Star metric?
North Star metric is
something that you
want to align with the
organization behind,
so that [INAUDIBLE] knows
what company goal is.
So at GO-JEK that would be
complete booking transactions.
So what is metrics
that matter when
we want to increase the
completed booking transactions?
We have also to increase
the total bookings.
We have also [INAUDIBLE]
the allocation
and reduce the
cancellation rate.
Total bookings is
the bookings that
get created by the
customer, and the allocation
is something that
we want to align
about the customer
and the driver.
And the cancellation
rate is when
the customer
created the booking,
the driver couldn't complete it.
And for that use case,
I'll just show you
that when the
allocation is mismatched
between the driver and the
customer, the completed
bookings wouldn't be reached.
So, how to rebalance
supply and demand?
And how do you view
it in real time?
So this is the GO-JEK
supply-demand use case.
So as a user, I
want to know which
location have mismatched
levels of supply and demand
in real time.
And I want to know the
particular drivers are
based on the real-time
data aggregation.
So if you see the
map in front of you,
if I hover our pointer in
the small dots with just
the driver, I can know driver
[INAUDIBLE] information
regarding the name, the
plate number, and also
the rating of the driver itself.
And I want to be able to
identify driver in low demand
area to move to
high demand area.
So after discussion, this is
the pipeline we already made.
And as you know, we have
so many pipeline here.
We have three big
pipelines in here.
The one is stream
booking count pipeline.
The second one is dimension
pipeline from the BigQuery
And stream driver
location pipeline,
we got from that Pub/Sub driver
location log or the driver
ping.
For your information,
our driver ping
is created every 10 seconds.
It means in that day, we have
more than 10 billion data
pings.
So from streaming
booking pipeline,
we can assume from our Pub/Sub
booking log, our messages.
And we created a model, which
by grouped the [INAUDIBLE]
ID, and also the status.
And we used sliding
window as animation
before the sliding window.
We are only concerned
about the current window.
And we filter with
[INAUDIBLE] status.
And the dimension pipeline,
we query from BigQuery
we go from tree table, location
table, service [INAUDIBLE],,
and also the driver profile.
Each of them, we have
created each model,
and we'll refresh
our window per day.
And on stream driver location
pipeline, we [INAUDIBLE]
from Pub/Sub driver
location log.
And we created a model,
and we use fixed window.
And after that, all of
them will be joined,
and will be stored to our
stream log memory store,
and our API we will call
the stream memory store,
and we will create
the mapping from this.
And we move to implementation.
For the implementation, we only
focus about the how we could.
So we just got the pipeline
using the Apache Beam SDK.
And we deployed it to the
Dataflow, and that's it.
We didn't spin up any machine,
any cluster, or Stackdriver.
What we have to do is
just push the [INAUDIBLE]
to the Apache Beam, and
Apache Beam will do the rest,
like creating the
machine, and create
the pipeline view
for us, and also
the Stackdriver by default.
And this, the pipeline
implementations
that already happened.
As you can see, this
is autoscale capability
of data, which means that
Dataflow can scale from one
worker to several worker,
based on how big your data
and how big your processing is.
And this is the scatter
map implementation
is fast forwarded.
Actually, it's refreshed
in every minute.
So the idea of the [? inside ?]
in here [INAUDIBLE]
don't last long, which is
good, because the booking might
be big in this area,
but not for a long time,
because the driver took
the order immediately,
so the aggregated booking that
created it will be disappearing
in there after several minutes.
But that is not enough.
How, if in the practical
area, there also canceled
booking happened in that day?
So if there are
many bookings, it
can be completed or canceled.
How can we make sure that
every booking is completed,
not cancelled?
So that's why we created
extended use cases.
And this is our
Cancellation alert use case--
previously, we got this chart
the day after, at day plus one,
and we couldn't see
that, oh, there's
something happened yesterday.
There's a spike of
cancellation yesterday.
But why was that happen?
That was too late, because
that was yesterday.
And maybe today,
it don't happen.
So as a user, I want to
be notified when there's
a huge cancellation
at that time,
so I can determine
the root cause
and fix it as soon as possible.
You know this pipeline before.
It's from our main use case.
From this use case, I want to
show you that in Apache Beam,
we can create [INAUDIBLE]
from this previous pipeline,
so we don't create
pipeline from scratch.
What we have to do is we have
the concern about the stream
booking count pipeline
only, because we
don't care about the dimension
pipeline and the stream driver
location pipeline,
so we move it out.
And after we get
the model, we just
group by booking status
and [INAUDIBLE] ID.
[INAUDIBLE] to sync
to Pub/Sub downstream,
and will be consumed by
our cancellation pipeline.
And the result
will be like this.
This is our Stackdriver.
For example, if the threshold
of canceled bookings
is more than 10%
of total booking,
it will give the alert.
And after it go
up the threshold,
it will give us the
alert, like this, alert,
cancelled bookings
more than 10%.
But again, that's not enough.
How do we know the reason?
After we get the alert, so what?
I couldn't do anything about it.
We have to know the reason
behind the cancelled booking.
And is there another
use case, again?
So as a user, I want to know
the reason cancelled booking
in real time.
And I want to notify
myself and the merchant
if item maybe sold
out, or maybe the price
differs with the apps and
the [INAUDIBLE] store,
or maybe store is closed
out of the scheduled.
And this is the new pipeline
that we have created.
We still consume from
our Pub/Sub booking log.
We filtered status by
the cancelled only,
and we create the
different model.
We created the group
by [INAUDIBLE] ID
and the cancelled reason,
and we use fixed window.
And then we sync to
our Pub/Sub downstream,
and we created
notification system.
And also, this pipeline
can synced to our BigQuery,
so our analysts can determine
their result better.
So this is the
JSON format that we
sync to the Pub/Sub downstream.
It include the [INAUDIBLE]
ID and the merchant name,
and also cancel reason, and
how many happened in that day.
So after the use
cases, three use cases,
I want to share with you
about the three takeaways that
are [INAUDIBLE]
about using Dataflow.
With Dataflow, we can create
streaming data processing.
We are able to solve business
with real-time data insight.
And Dataflow delivers high
performance scalability
with minimal
operational maintenance,
as you already get that.
Dataflow can scale from
one to several workers,
based on how big your data and
how complex your processing is.
And our report will be
delivered less than a
day, so our analysts
can do more,
getting more insight
with more recent data.
And that's all for me.
Back to you, Anand.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
ANAND IYER: Thank you, Syarif.
Please do stay on stage.
So it's always useful
and quite fascinating
to hear about real
implementations from customers.
And I guess one thing
I want to highlight,
which was particularly
fascinating,
was the fact that they
built one complex use case,
and then they found
out, oh, guess what?
I can take what
I've implemented,
and with small tweaks,
convert it into a new use.
So that was quite fascinating.
And the tools on GCP
do enable that easily.
So if you want to learn more,
please point your browsers
to this URL.
So essentially,
cloud.google.com, solutions,
under the big data category,
streaming analytics.
And from that
website, it has links
to other deeper
information that you
might want to get access to.
So please do direct your
browsers to that website.
And with that, thank you
for listening to our talk.
We hope it was useful for you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]